We get support from UC Davis, a globally ranked university, working to solve the world's most pressing problems in food, energy, health, education, and the environment. UC Davis researchers collaborate and innovate in California and around the globe to find transformational solutions. It's all part of the university's mission to promote quality of life for all living things. Find out more at 21stCentury.ucdavis.edu. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. If you look at the outer hull of commercial ships down by the water line, you might find a painted circle bisected with a long horizontal line.
我们得到加州大学戴维斯分校的支持，这是一所全球知名的大学，致力于解决世界在食品、能源、健康、环境和教育领域最紧迫的问题。加州大学戴维斯分校的研究人员在加州及全球各地合作创新，寻找变革性的解决方案。这完全符合该大学促进所有生物生活质量的使命。请访问 21stCentury.ucdavis.edu 了解更多信息。这里是《99%无形》。我是罗曼·马斯。如果你观察商业船舶水线附近的外部船体，你可能会发现一个画着水平线穿过中心的圆圈。
The simple marking is called the load line, or as I prefer, the plimso line. And not to oversell it, but this elegant graphic design has saved thousands of lives. This is one of my favorite examples of design because what I really like in the world is when you can find a massive problem that definitely needs solving and with some thought you can solve it with something as simple as a circle with a line for it. It's just find it amazing. That's what I'd like to do with my career.
这个简单的标记被称为载重线，或者我更愿意称之为普利姆索尔线。毫不夸张地说，这个优雅的平面设计已经拯救了数千人的生命。这是我最喜欢的设计例子之一，因为我真正欣赏的是，当你能发现一个绝对需要解决的宏大问题，并且通过一些思考，就能用像带有一条线的圆圈这样简单的事物来解决它时。我只是觉得这太神奇了。这也是我想在职业生涯中做的事情。
That's Tristan Cook. And I make human factors engineer so that means that I look at the way that people interact with their environment and figure out how that will affect their behavior. Tristan also curates an outstanding blog called Humans in Design. So anyway, the massive problem that needed solving in the 19th century that Tristan is referring to was the huge number of British ships sinking in the ocean because they were overloaded and in disrepair, sending hundreds of merchant seamen to a watery grave. The problem was so widespread that these vessels became known by another name.
那是特里斯坦·库克。我是一名人类工效学工程师，这意味着我研究人们与环境互动的方式，并弄清楚这将如何影响他们的行为。特里斯坦还策划了一个出色的博客，名为“设计中的人类”。总之，特里斯坦所提到的19世纪需要解决的巨大问题是，大量英国船只因超载和失修而在海洋中沉没，将数百名商船海员送入水墓。这个问题非常普遍，以至于这些船只获得了另一个名字。
Coffin ships? Coffin ships. Now overloading ships has certainly happened since their have been ships to overload, but it was the introduction of insurance that created the Coffin ship. It's still a colloquial term for ships that are over-insured, so they worth more money to the person that owns them at the bottom of the ocean and they are a float. So ship owners would purposefully overload older ships with cargo, thinking that if the ships made it, they hit the jackpot. But if the ships didn't make it, they still made a lot of money on the insurance claim.
棺材船？棺材船。现在，超载船舶的现象自从有了需要超载的船只以来就一直存在，但正是保险的引入创造了“棺材船”。它至今仍然是对那些过度投保的船只的俗称，对船东来说，它们沉在海底比浮在水面上更有价值。因此，船东会故意在旧船上超载货物，心想如果船只成功抵达，他们就发财了。但如果船只没有抵达，他们依然能通过保险索赔赚一大笔钱。
Early days in insurance, so people weren't quite aware of the idea that by ensuring something you're going to change and affect people's behavior. This is called a moral hazard when people engage in risky behavior because they are not fully accountable for the consequences. You'd assume that insurance is going to keep everything the same, but it doesn't. When something is insured, it changes your behavior, you become more risky, or you have a different incentive to do something. And the unintended consequence of insurance was that ship owners had an incentive to sink their
那是保险的早期阶段，所以人们并没有意识到通过为某事投保会改变和影响人们的行为这一概念。当人们因为不必完全承担后果而从事风险行为时，这就被称为道德风险。你可能会假设保险会让一切保持原样，但事实并非如此。当某事受保时，它会改变你的行为，你会变得更加冒险，或者对做某事产生不同的动机。而保险的意料之外的后果是，船东有了故意沉没他们
own ships and send hundreds of souls to the bottom of the ocean. The most famous one was one called the SS London. It had 230 something people on board. It was leaving a place and I'm not kidding, called Graves End in England, theoretically headed for Melbourne, Australia. But it was overloaded with a whole bunch of railway parts and things like that. And that was in the mid-1800s and that sank as in a storm like when it tried to turn back towards a port. This is where our hero, British MP Samuel Plimpsol and the Plimpsol line comes in. Just after that happened, a guy called Samuel Plimpsol, and the Plimpsol line comes in. Just after that happened, a guy called Samuel Plimpsol got elected to the British Parliament, and he wanted to pass a bunch of new shipping safety laws based upon his knowledge of this
自己的船并把数百条灵魂送入海底的动机。其中最著名的一艘叫做“伦敦号”。它载有230多人。它离开了一个地方——说真的，我没开玩笑——叫做英国的格雷夫森德，理论上是前往澳大利亚墨尔本。但它超载了大量铁路零件之类的东西。那是在19世纪中叶，它在试图掉头返回港口的一场风暴中沉没了。这就是我们的英雄、英国议员塞缪尔·普利姆索尔和普利姆索尔线登场的时候。就在那件事发生后不久，一个叫塞缪尔·普利姆索尔的人当选为英国议员，他想根据他对这起
disaster. But passing these safety laws was not easy for Plimpsol because it just so happens that murderous, regulation- regulation hating immoral capitalists and their friends sometimes serve as elected officials. A lot of the people in British Parliament owned ships so they were the owners that didn't want extra regulation so yeah here it had actually a fairly large amount of trouble getting it through. It didn't sail through it had very little support in Parliament.
灾难的了解，通过一系列新的航运安全法。但对普利姆索尔来说，通过这些安全法并不容易，因为碰巧的是，那些谋杀成性、仇恨监管的非道德资本家及其朋友有时会担任民选官员。英国议会中的许多人拥有船只，因此他们是不想要额外监管的船东，所以是的，这项法案在这里遇到了相当大的阻力。它并没有顺利通过，在议会中得到的支持非常少。
So Plum Sol took his case to the people. Plimzel wrote a book called Our Seaman, which it was really championed the issue, and that went really wide. And eventually due to widespread public support, the merchant shipping act of 1876 was passed. It required the simple, elegant graphic I described earlier, a circle with a long horizontal line at the center, to be painted on the outside of the hall to show the maximum loading point of the ship. The mark let a third party know plainly and clearly when of us was being overloaded and at risk of sinking in rough seas.
于是，普利姆索尔将他的诉求直接带给了民众。普利姆索尔写了一本名为《我们的海员》的书，这本书真正大力倡导了这个议题，并产生了广泛的影响。最终，由于广泛的公众支持，1876年《商船法》得以通过。该法案要求在船体外侧画出我之前描述的那个简单而优雅的图形——一个中心有一条长水平线的圆圈，以显示船只的最大载货点。这个标记让第三方能够清晰明了地知道船只何时超载，并面临在恶劣海况下沉没的风险。
If you see that horizontal line above the water, you're good, and if you don't, well, you could be sunk. It's kind of really pretty looking to look at. That's what drew me to it initially. It's very geometric. And some form of the plums online remains on ships to this day. There's just a slight modification
如果你看到那条水平线在水面上，那就没问题；如果没有，嗯，你可能就要沉了。它看起来真的很漂亮。这也是最初吸引我的原因。它非常几何化。直到今天，某种形式的普利姆索尔线仍然保留在船只上。只是做了一些微小的修改，
so that in different waters or saltwater or fresh water or with different sorts of ships, you're allowed to load it to different levels. So there's just a couple of different levels on the outside. Personally, I think it's amazing that with Boats Seas days, that there's all these different safety measures that have been implemented. There's GPS, the Boats drive themselves halfway through everywhere, but when it gets down to it, the thing that is most importantly, keeping a boat afloat, is still just a circle with a line through it
以便在不同的水域、咸水、淡水或针对不同类型的船只时，允许其装载到不同的深度。因此，外部会有几个不同的水位标记。就我个人而言，我觉得很神奇的是，如今有了各种各样的安全措施应用在船只上。有GPS，船只在许多地方都能半自动驾驶，但归根结底，最重要、能够让船只浮在水面上的东西，依然只是船体上画着一条线的圆圈，只是一层油漆。
on its hull, just a bit of paint. There have been numerous poems and songs sung about Samuel Plumsol, but over time his name has faded even though his mark on the world lives on. It's actually less known as a Plumsol line now, or more as a low line, but at the time it was definitely known as a Plumsol line. But if I've done my job today, you dear listener, will only call it a Plim Soul Line because it seems like the right and honorable thing. And besides, if there's an opportunity to use an eponym, use the eponym, it's just cooler. Our tar is upon the ocean, he struggles to defend. Success the Samuel Plimself, for he is the sailor's friend.
曾有无数的诗歌和歌曲歌颂塞缪尔·普利姆索尔，但随着时间的推移，他的名字逐渐淡出人们的视线，尽管他留在世界上的印记依然存在。现在人们更少称它为普利姆索尔线，更多称之为载重线，但在当时它绝对被称为普利姆索尔线。但如果我今天的工作做好了，亲爱的听众，你只会称它为普利姆索尔线，因为这似乎是正确且光荣的做法。此外，如果有机会使用同源词，那就用同源词，那样更酷。我们的海员在海洋上，他挣扎着保卫。向塞缪尔·普利姆索尔致敬，因为他是水手的益友。
99% of visible was produced this week by me, Roman Mars, with help from Tristan Cook and Tom Nelson, who curate the blog Humans in Design. This program was made possible with support from Lunar, making a difference with creativity. It's a project of KALW 91.7 local public radio in San Francisco, the American Institute of Architects in San Francisco, and the Center for Architecture and Design. To find out more including a link to the blog, humans, and design, go to our website, it's 99% invisible.org. For a year, let's go nowhere If you stop, you'll end up somewhere In a minute, I need one second to jump down Everybody wants a quarter jump down
本周的《99%无形》由我罗曼·马斯制作，并得到了特里斯坦·库克和汤姆·纳尔逊的协助，他们策划了“设计中的人类”博客。本程序是在 Lunar 的支持下制作的，Lunar 用创意创造改变。这是旧金山 KALW 91.7 本地公共广播电台、美国建筑师学会旧金山分会以及建筑与设计中心的一个项目。欲了解更多信息（包括指向“设计中的人类”博客的链接），请访问我们的网站 99percentinvisible.org。有一年，让我们去虚无缥缈的地方如果你停下来，你终究会到达某个地方在一分钟内，我需要一秒钟跳下去每个人都想要一个25美分硬币跳下去
Everybody wants a quarter jump down Everybody just goes past You're a man's. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
每个人都想要一个25美分硬币跳下去每个人都只是擦肩而过你是曼恩。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下面评。